Yeah, that's my opinion,
hmm,
ana,
how are
you, ua, are you serious? What does this mean
?
It
's only for a moment when I pick up speed, is
n't it?
Well, if it's going to be built in the end, the name of the place to kill will be quick to talk about
What's the intention of that line
?  Of course
, I didn't see it that way, but
let's get that filthy thing out of the division
Law didn't seem jealous of being rehabilitated in
prison naoahhhhh I
'm in trouble if he rampages too much
[music]
worrying about betrayal  It's useless, I want to show them. That's
what
I gave them as a condition of exchange.
I mean, when I hear the way you talk about trying to take it, I want to chop off your head
Wow,
we're dogs with collars.
Chance, I'll be serious about my mission too
.